indeed fabi congratulations on winning
two games today but you must have felt
like christmas came early when wesley
dropped the knight on f5 and gifted you
this game yeah i i don't know exactly
what happened uh in his calculations
um
i assume he just didn't realize i could
play gf5 he just didn't even think about
the move that's the only explanation i
can come up with and he was maybe
looking at
bishop f5 or queen c7 or some other
move um yeah
it's definitely a pleasant uh
pleasant gift to get you reacted
quite strongly when it happened we could
see you like what did you think you had
missed something
no i mean we see you here on camera by
the way you can see yourself uh you're
like what
what's happening here
well the thing is i i did see that
i didn't think about this move in
advance so i saw
that he's that c2 is hanging um
so i just
couldn't believe it when he played it um
and then i think he realized like a
second later that something was wrong
because he started to
slightly shake his head
but he realized it himself you had a bad
start to the day sam shanklin
put some moves in and uh was able to
roll up this attack against you would
you imagine you were to bounce back in
such a fine way winning your next two
games
yeah no the first game i
i was a bit worse throughout the game
and then at some point
i felt like i'd equalized pretty much
completely and i could trade queens and
i thought it was an equal end game
um
and then i made a decision mostly
because he was much lower on time to try
to
keep some chances in the position
and then at some point it just got so
unpleasant it was like
i i didn't
realize that he could play f45 and when
i allowed that i was
i was pretty upset because it suddenly
got extremely unpleasant and then rook
f3 also had underestimated
and then i didn't see any way to deal
with
this attack except what i did and i
still thought there was chances because
it's very complicated
um maybe i still had some chances not to
lose the game but
it was uh i think he played well and it
was probably also a very very bad
position objectively
um
but yeah i i was lucky in the next two
games i mean also against lanier it
wasn't necessary for him to lose that
position
your feelings now
standing alone in first place you were
tied yesterday but now you managed to
extend the lead
yeah it seems like most people who had a
good day yesterday uh had a
had a good day yesterday had a bad day
today and vice versa like sam
uh and lanier basically
reversed the results and ended up in the
same position
um
so yeah it
but that's i guess the nature of rapid
that uh
everything can change pretty much in one
game correct me if i'm wrong
i don't recall you ever winning a grand
chest to a
rapid and blitz event
no i haven't
how does it feel with the opportunity
you're two points ahead of the pack
right now
let's not get ahead of ourselves i mean
there's still
even after the three raptor games
there's 18 rounds of blitz
i think 18 rounds is a pretty serious
amount so
uh but it's good to to be in first place
indeed i think a lot of fans hoping that
you win congratulations on your day and
good luck in the rest of the games thank
you congratulations fabi but just a
quick question for if you will for us
calling the action okay uh 60 decisive
games in day one right that was pretty
uh crazy but day two
uh the craziness has continued uh we
just see
some incredible blunders and incredible
wins uh shaq you we don't know what to
make of shaq's form he's up and down
what's it like in the playing hall
realizing that people are doing crazy
things what's going on upstairs
well i think it's really because nobody
can can see the pieces i mean most of
the players wear glasses and also wear
masks
and i saw wesley trying desperately to
try to get his glasses not to fog up
so
maybe that's why
chatriar doesn't wear glasses
was the lightning impactful by the way
we were told that upstairs there was
some lightning
i didn't hear anything
you did you were okay you were done by
then all right yeah okay well thank you
for that and what can i say keep up the
good form i don't know what to say what
is the secret to being
go to the grand chester you get lasik
surgery